you were obviously clearly a Republican
you're no longer a Republican what
caused what caused the break
I'm a non-practicing Republican do you
know anything so you know I'm still I'm
still it's hard to recognize was there a
moment for you when you thought I'm not
part of what those people may be
Republicans or that person may be a
Republican but I'm not going with that I
mean honestly I think in 2008 to work
for John McCain who is also in in pretty
bad shape health-wise I mean to see that
Sarah Palin's crowds were bigger and
more enthusiastic for the crazy things
she was saying than his was really the
canary in the mind and the signal that
the party had changed to telling you
that something was happening in this
country that was angrier and more
extreme darker yeah and and I thought
like if she gave me my first shove you
know trumpism gave me my last kick out
the door right right no I understand
that now your family though you are
Trump supporters is that your your your
your mother and father yeah I don't know
that they know that I have a show on
MSNBC like I think they've heard that I
think they don't know I'm here when
people say like we love your daughter
they always call me they're like why
does my doctor know who you are I'm like
I have no idea they honestly have no
idea
have they ever seen your show I don't
know I don't know about my parents know
I have a show when won't watch it
that's different that's very different
yours yours just happen not to know
which i think is a sweeter truth
[Applause]
probably but mommy water all the way but
it's good not to fight about it because
they're great grandparents they're great
parents but there is no and this is the
thing about having friends that are
still Republicans that are trouble
Republicans all those friendships are by
and large on ice because there is no
sort of talking to both sides of the
question it's sort of like you know
we've hit rough seas sort of like a
dummy Daniel's anyway I just wanted to
say stormy Daniels I just won $100 do
you call her pornstars stormy Daniels or
I mean now that she's going toe-to-toe
with the president I wrestle every day
with whether she's adult film actress
stormy Daniels or poor dude she and I go
way back
and I I still want to get involved she's
a friend
so
you